SPEAKER 1: The process of
writing and running SQL queries
doesn't always follow
a straight line.
A particular query can
be in constant iteration
while you use it to explore
and clean up your data,
or as you fine tune it to
optimize its performance.
In today's episode, we highlight
the ways to save and share
queries in BigQuery
to help you navigate
these bends in the road.
[THEME MUSIC]
So you ran a query last
Friday for your colleague
and sent them the results.
All done, right?
Wrong.
It's Monday morning,
and now there's
another request for additional
data fields on the same query.
The new request requires you to
join data from another table--
a join which you actually
did in a separate query
a few weeks ago.
But you can't quite
remember how you did it.
Do you really want to write
a new SQL query from scratch?
No.
I mean, it's great practice,
but it's not always
the most practical.
Luckily, BigQuery
has features built
in that allow you to
view your query history,
proactively save
specific queries,
and share queries with others.
Let's take a look at each of
these features a bit further.
Your first line of defense
for revisiting past queries
in BigQuery is
your query history.
This feature is automatic
and includes the text
of all queries you have run.
You can view your query
history in the console
by selecting Query History
in the top left-hand nav.
Click on a specific
query and you'll
see the text of the query and
be able to open it in the editor
so you can modify and rerun it.
Just note, this history is
limited to 1,000 queries
and looks back up to six months.
Going a step further, you can
decide to proactively name
and save a specific query.
Just enter the query, valid
or not, in the editor.
Then click Save
Query, located just
to the right of the Run button.
Give the query a name
and then click Save.
You can find a list
of your saved queries
in the left-hand nav.
Similar to the functionality
in your query history,
you can now click to open
the query in the editor,
modify it, and run it.
If you want to share one of
your queries with a colleague,
you can create shared queries.
You can create a shared query
by first saving a query,
turning on link sharing, and
then sharing the unique URL.
A shared query provides
the query text only,
so users that open
your shared query
will still need to
have appropriate access
to the tables referenced in
the query to be able to run it.
For more information on
how to share access to data
sets using Identity and Access
Management, or IAM, watch
our last episode, "Managing
Access with Cloud IAM,"
linked in the description below.
Other users will be
restricted from editing
your personal saved queries.
If you're looking to make
saved queries editable
by your team
members, you'll need
to change the saved query
visibility to Project
and then grant your team
members the permissions to get,
list, and update saved
queries on your project.
So now that you have the
text of the query covered,
what about the query results?
Just as BigQuery automatically
saves your query history,
it also by default
caches the results
of your successfully run
queries in temporary tables.
These tables expire
after 24 hours.
And within this time, you
can browse the results
through your query history.
Just select the query
and scroll to find
a link to the temporary table.
Here you can preview the data
and also export the full table
to cloud storage.
If you rerun the query, BigQuery
will use the cached results
if it can, meaning if you are
still within the 24-hour period
and the underlying data
has not had any changes.
By using cached results, you
won't incur any query costs.
Temporary tables are available
only to the specific user
that runs the query.
So if you're looking to
share the query results,
you should consider saving
them to a permanent table.
You can make the switch from
saving in a temporary table
to a permanent table by
opening the query settings
and setting a destination
table for the results.
Click Run.
And after the query
is complete, you
will see the new table
in the left-hand nav.
You can then use IAM to
share the destination data
set or table with
your collaborators.
It's important to note,
permanent tables will
incur storage costs, while
temporary tables do not.
Another method for
sharing results
is to use the option to
save them immediately
after running your query.
Click the Save Results
button and choose
between several options
for saving results--
locally, in Google Drive, or
directly to a Google Sheet.
We've now reviewed how to save
and share query text and query
results.
But there is one more tool to
cover, which is called views.
A view is a virtual
table defined by a query.
A view can be queried just
like you query a table.
Views are listed next
to tables in a data set,
denoted with a different icon.
When running a query
that references a view,
BigQuery will also run the
query that defines that view.
So why would views be helpful?
Views can help hide
the complexity of data
by allowing you to
join multiple tables
into a single virtual
table ready to query.
Views can be a good alternative
to sharing query text,
because then you can take
advantage of the finer grain
controls available
in Cloud IAM to share
the view and the
underlying tables.
Views do not require storage.
Since they're virtual
tables, there's
not a storage cost
associated with them.
To create a view,
write the query
that defines the view
in the Query Editor
and then click Save View.
Choose the project
and data set where
you'd like the view to live,
and then give the view a name.
Click Save.
The view will populate under
the destination data set
and can be queried just
like you query a table.
Now that you know how to
save and share queries,
it's time for you to try.
If you haven't created
your BigQuery sandbox,
do so by following
the link below.
Once you're in the console,
click Add Data, Explore Public
Data Sets, and then pick
out your favorite one.
Write a query and share it with
a friend and in the comments
below, if you like.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And remember, stay curious.
[THEME MUSIC]